اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من خان يونس جنوب
قطاع غزه اهلا بكم عدد الشهداء في قطاع
غزه يتجاوزوا
4100 وتنديد بالقصف الاسرائيلي لكنيسه
الروم الارثوذكس وسط غزه والذي خلف 16
شهيدا وجوش يدعو من رفح الى وقف اطلاق نار
غير مشروط ويقول ان هناك شروطا تعيق وصول
المساعدات الى غزه رغم الاتفاق على
ادخالها ناطق باسم القسام ابو عبيده يقول
ان المقاومه مستعده لمعركه طويله ووزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي يقول ان اهداف الحرب هي
تصفيه حماس وخلق نظام امني جديد في حين
كشف مستشار نتنياهو ان عدد الاسرى لدى
حماس قد يرتفع بسبب وجود مفقودين 13 شهيدا
في اشتباكات بمخيم نور شمس في طول كرم
وارتفاع اجمالي الشهداء في الضفه منذ
السابع من اكتوبر الى 881 والفصائل
الفلسطينيه تقول انها نصبت كمينا لقوه
اسرائيليه في المخيم وحققت اصابات مؤكده
بينما اكد الجيش الاسرائيلي مقتل جندي من
وحده المستعربين على الحدود اللبنانيه
الاسرائيليه الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول انه
هاجم ثلاثه من مسلحي حزب الله في منطقه
السياج الحدودي ووسائل اعلام اسرائيليه
تقول ان مسلحا تسلل من لبنان واطلق النار
على نقطه حراسه في بلده مرجليوث في حين
بدات سلطات الاحتلال في اجلاء كل سكان
مستوطنه كريات شمول الى
اللقاء